hello and welcome to this tutorial
i'm antonio papa from
scalablescripts.com
and in this tutorial we will create a
microservices example
using python and react let's start by
understanding
what is a monolith and what are
microservices
a monolith can be a large code base that
has a lot of functionalities
and is connected with a single big
database
in this example that i'm showing you you
can think
this as a nicomer site
we have a search functionality that has
a lot of traffic
we have a product list which are cached
we have a product recommendation
functionality
we which we can use machine learning to
recommend different products
and we have a contact page where we have
less traffic there
the problem with this architecture is if
we want to scale this up
because the search has a lot of traffic
we have to replicate
all the functionalities so we are
replicating
also the parts of the code that has no
traffic like
the contact page also since it is
one repository there can be only one
language
and you can cause other problems with
other teams if which
if you change their code since there is
only one repository
now what are microservices microservices
are
smaller independent services that have
their own database
and they can communicate with each other
using an event
bus so in our example we will have four
microservices
all have their own database and they
will communicate with each other
via messages the advantages in this case
are that we can scale the applications
based on the traffic so if we see the
search microservice we scaled
that microservice four times compared
to the contact where we have only one
instance of the contact microservice
another advantage
is the separation of concerns now the
product recommendation team
can only focus on machine learning and
not scaling
up the application also each team
can use a different programming language
based on their needs
now let's jump to the application that
we will build
in this example we will build a simple
microservices example
using python the front end of this app
will be built with angular react view
and swelt you can pick your favorite
there
the backend is composed into two apps an
admin app
and the main app the admin app will be
built using django
and the main app will be built using
flask
both will run in docker and will connect
with their own database in mysql
they will communicate with each other
using rabbitmq
events and in one case the main app
will internally call the admin app
now let's see what this app looks like
so this is the app that we will build
it's a simple app where this is the
admin
and this is the main app in the main app
we can like the products and in the
admin app we can create the products
it is very simple but don't get deceived
because
it it has two backend apps with
different database
communicating with rabbitmq which i open
it on my right side
so let's see an example for example i
will like this
product here and when i like the product
you will see an event happening in
rabbitmq right now
so the event has been triggered here
and we have one ready event and now is
zero so
it means it was consumed so if we see
here
let's refresh the admin we can see that
we got another like here so in essence
it's really simple
but this like
has more functionality to it since it
will
internally call also the admin to get a
random user
and if we happen to like with
the same user it will throw an error
we can also create a new product
so let's create a product
and i will add a sample image
we will see that rabbitmq will trigger
another event
so this is a product that we created
another head event has been fired
and when it's consumed here we will
see the product here
so it seems that the product is
on the admin app on the main app
so we got the product so we will see
how this app will work by building them
so
let's start creating the apps
so let's start building the admin app
using django rest
framework to create the project go to
tutorial
quick start and these are the commands
to create a simple
django project you have to install
django
and jungle rest framework from pip
i already did it so i can directly go to
the terminal
and write django admin
start project
admin and the project is created i can
go to the folder now
and run python 3
manage that pi run server
so the project is running now and i can
copy this url
and paste it to the browser and we can
see that
we successfully installed the django
project
now let's open the project with our ide
and this is the app that we just
generated now
let's run docker so let's create two
files
one is docker file
and the other one is docker compose
dot yaml file
so let's open the docker file first
and what we will write here is first
from what type of project is this so we
want to get it from python
and we have to specify the version of
python i will
pick the latest one which is 3.9
next we will add an environment variable
python and buffered one
because this is useful to get logs so we
can see whatever
is happening and now we have to specify
a working directory i will call it just
up so before going further
i will create a requirements
txt file so in this file we can put all
the dependencies that we will use
in our app so i will paste them here
we will use django django rest framework
mysql client
and java mysql so we will connect with
mysql
jungle course headers this is needed for
the front end
to access the backend and pica this is
useful
when we will connect with a rabbitmq
now that we added our requirements let's
go to the docker file
and we will copy requirements.txt
to up let's copy the
name here requirements.txt so
we are copying this file to the work to
the working directory requirements
so we are copying inside the docker
container
and now we have to install it so we have
to run a command
pip install minus
r requirements so paste it
so this will install all these
requirements
and in the end we will copy all the
files
so dot slash up
dot in this case means all the files
here so
we are copying all the files to the app
directory
the last command is running the
project so we have to add here python
manage that pi run server
and we also need to specify the host so
the host will be
0.0.0 0.0.0.0 with port 8000
so we have to use it this way otherwise
we cannot connect
the port with our localhost
now let's go to our docker compose file
here we have to start by adding the
version
the latest version of docker compose is
3.8
and then we have to specify the services
so for the moment i will just
add the backend service
which is our app here first we have to
specify the docker file so build
we have to put here context which which
is this folder
and the docker file which is docker file
so basically this means that this docker
compose file should use this docker file
so that's it next we need to
specify a port here
so this port that is running here is
inside the docker container is not our
local host so we have to
tell our localhost
to listen to a specific port so in
my case this is the dockerfile port
and this is our localhost port so if we
don't
use this we won't be able to access
the server and the last change
is the volumes so add here volumes
and inside we will specify dot
column up
this means that dot
means all the files here are connected
with the docker container every time we
make a change in the
app it will pass it to the
slash to the docker file up and
the opposite if change happens in the
docker file
it will reflect it here so
that's it this is our app now we have to
start it
first we have to stop the server
here and open the terminal
and write docker compose up
now he's building the back end is
downloading all the required libraries
for python and
it will also install all the
requirements here
let's wait till it's completed so now
everything is running correctly we can
see that
the development server is running
and also we stopped the server from this
uh
terminal and if we refresh now
we'll see we'll get the same page now
this is running from the docker
container
if we stop for example we won't be able
to see it so
now we don't see it if i start again
now it will be much more faster
so we can see it so this is how
you connect django with docker
now we have to connect with the database
we already have an sqlite database here
but
we will remove it because
we will be using mysql so the first
thing we have to add
the mysql service i will call it db
and here i will add an image which is
mysql
version 5.7.22
so we added mysql next we have to
add restart always
so we have to add this command because
uh sometimes
mysql stops and this will stop also our
docker container and our app
is no will not run so this will restart
it again
next we have to add some environment
variables so these are
some environment variables that we will
connect with our
backend so we have to add mysql database
which is admin mysql
user root
mysql password
i will also put root here and mysql
root password root
so these values you can pick whatever
values you want so
you can specify them here next we have
to add volumes
so this is really important so mysql
when we start when it stores data
it needs to map them to a folder so i
will create a folder here db
data which will map var
lib mysql
so all the files here will be reflected
to a folder here called
db data so we will see that once we
start this
container so we are finished
now we have to add here ports this is
not
required at all i will just add it so we
can see
the data inside the database so the port
will be the default
port for mysql is 3306 and this is
inside the docker container outside
we will use 33066
or whatever port we want i didn't put
the same port because it will conflict
with my mysql installation
so that's it the last change
is we should add here depends on db
this means that this container should
run
first and then this container should run
now let's
close it and start it again
now it's pulling mysql
so we can see now the database is
running
so we can also see a db data folder here
so this are the files that when we store
anything
it will be reflected here we don't have
to touch this
folder so this is just there to stay
now let's connect with our
ide so we need a new data source mysql
and our port was 33066
root for the user root for the password
and the database was
admin let's test
if we connect so we connected
successfully
now we have only one schema with no
tables
so now let's add some tables to the
database
first we have to create a new app so we
have to go inside the docker container
now
so to go inside the docker container
open a new terminal and write
docker compose exec
now we need the name of the service
which in our case is backend
backend sh
we are inside now and now let's run a
juggle command to create a new app so
python
manage that pi startup
products
so we created the app we can see here
the products is created and we run the
command inside the docker container
now let's uh go to admin
and we need to connect we need to add
this
products to the installed apps first we
have to add here
rest framework
next we have to add here course
headers and the products
that we just created our course headers
needs also
a middleware so this is a middleware
that we need to add
and also it needs a new constant i will
add it here in the end
course origin allow all so we added
everything we need
now we need to connect with mysql
here we have to change this sqlite to
mysql
the name of the database would be admin
next we have to add the user
which is root the password
which is also root the host
those is no in our case will be this
service here so just db
db and the port
and in this case we won't be using this
port but we will use the port inside
this
service so is 3306
so i 3306
so this is our connection with mysql
we can remove again this sql light here
and uh let's restart
again the docker containers now we have
to run migrations to create
tables in mysql so let's go to the
products
and models so we will create two models
here the first one
is product
this will extend from models model
and we will add the fields for the
product that we need
title which is models
a chair field with a max length of 200
let's do the same for the image
and we need another field which is likes
this will be a positive in the
integer field and the default value will
be zero
so this is our product and we need
another
table now i'll call it user
models model so we won't be really
using the user table we will just use
the user id so
i'll just pass so with this
this table will have only the id field
and the product will have the id and
these other three fields
so now we have the models we need to
generate migrations for these models
and we have to migrate so open the
terminal
let's go inside the docker container
again
and here we have to write
python manage that pi
make migrations
so we can see we generated migrations
these are the migrations that we
generated
and to run them run python
make manage that pi
migrate
so we run all the migrations if we open
the database now
and refresh we'll see a bunch of tables
we won't be using all these tables the
only two tables that we are interested
is the products which we have title
image and likes and the user which
has only the id field so this is how we
connect django
with mysql and we run migrations
so we created our models and now django
when we
return the objects in an api we need to
use serializers so
now i'll create a folder a file here
sorry
serializers
and inside i will create a class
product serializer
this will extend from serializers
so let's import it first from
rest framework import
serializers and this will extend from
serializers
dot model serializer
so inside we'll add another class which
is meta
and we have to tell which is the model
in our case is a product
let's import the product here so i will
remove this
so we said that the product is a model
and now we have to specify the fields
and i will use all of them
so this is our serializer is very
simple we won't be using a serializer
for the user
since we will return a random id there
now let's go to the views and now we
will use the serializers so
here we will create all the five methods
for rest api crowd
so there are multiple ways to do it
in my case i will use the view set so
from so i will
remove the render from django
so rest framework sorry import
view set and
what we'll do with this view set is we
will create a class
product view set
this will extend from view sets
view set so this will have a
five methods that we want so i will add
here
list this will be the list of uh
the products so i will list them
one by one so this needs a request
so i will add here
create self
request also so these
are for slash products route
for slash product slash so i will write
it here
this is r4 i will add a comment
slash api slash products
route i'll let pass here so it won't
throw an error
so this will have a get request this
will have a post request
now there are other endpoints
that we will use which is def retrieve
in itself request and
the primary key which is known by
default
and this will be like
this so i will added
string id
and i will pass it here so there are
three
methods for a single product
one is retrieve the other one is update
and the last one is delete
so these are all the five methods
now i'll remove the this part
so to use these methods
we have to add here a new file
urls i'll copy the same
code from this admin urls here
i'll paste it here and here we will use
products i'll remove the slash
and what is this next parameter
it will be product
view set let's import it
from views we have to edit here
as a view but we still need
extra parameters we have to tell that
the get method
will point to the list function
so as we can see here we have a list
and the get method will point to this
list function
the post method will point to the
create function and we have to add
another router
right now for product slash
the it needs a string which is a primary
key
and this get method now we will call the
retrieve function
we don't have a post we have a put here
this will point to update
and delete
will point to destroy so i made a
mistake
this is destroyer
so now all the methods are here now
let's use them
first let's add the list of the products
so first
let's get the products we have to get
the product here
objects all of them
let's import this product from models
so we got all the products now we need
to use the serializer we just created so
serializer
is equal to product serializer
let's also import it so imported product
serializer here
the first parameter is the products
and we need another parameter here we
have to tell
that many is equal to true so we have
this is a list of the products and it
needs to return
an array now that we got the serializer
we need to return response
with serializer that data let's import
also the response here
from rest framework response
so this is the import
so this is our list function let's see
how it
looks like so i open postman here you
have to install it to test
the apis here i will use http
localhost port 8000
slash i forgot also
one other thing so we added the routes
here
i also need to add them here
first let's import from django url
0 we will import include
and let's add the new path
which will start with api
we'll add a slash here and we will
include here
our project which is products so this
project
dot urls which is this file
now that we included now we can use it
here
is api slash products
and normally we don't have any product
so
it will return an empty array now let's
add the next
function which is create
here we'll get the serializer
which is equal to product serializer and
we have to pass the data from the
request
so data is equal to request the data
so we will use those data and we have to
first
call is valid so if
we send valid data to this serializer
if not we will erase an exception
and if it's valid it means we will go to
this line
it means we'll save it
after we save it we return the response
so response
serializer.data and we have to put a
status here so
we'll import from status
let's import status
so i don't remember the exact import
here but we'll use status is equal to
status
dot http
201 created
let's import this status
so it's from rest framework we'll import
status here
now let's use it so we will change this
from get to post and we will
send some
from json here we'll send
some request we need the title
title and an image
which is image let's send the request
and we return the title notice that we
get also the likes here
by default is zero we got also an id
so our first product is created if we go
to the get
method now we'll see an array with a
one product so this is
the create function the retrieve
is really simple we have to get the
product
which is equal product objects get
the id is equal to this primary key
now that we got the product we have to
get the serializer
is equal to product serializer with the
product
and we have to return in response
serializer.data
let's use it so this has id1 so
if we put a get request with id 1 we
return a
single object products returns
an array of objects
now let's go to the update let's copy
this part
i'll put it to the update and also
destroy because we will use the
object there so we'll get the serializer
here
is equal to product serializer we have
to pass the
instance which is this product so the
instance is a product
with the data that it has and we have to
update it with a new data
which we will get it from the request
the data
so this is a project that the product
that we have
and these are the data that we want to
update it
now we have to do the same thing we have
to
ask if the serializer is valid then we
have to
save in the end we'll return a response
with the serializer.data and we have to
change the status which is
202 accepted
so let's change product with id1
we'll send a boost reboot request here
and this is new
title and the new image
send requests and we can see that these
values are changed now
also the status is 202 accepted
last change is destroying the object
this is really simple we have to call
product
delete and that's it so we have to
return here
response with the status
status http 204 no content
so let's delete this product
send the request and we have 24 no
content
we don't have a product and if we go to
the products
uh not delete method so
we have still an empty array now here
now the last call that we need is
the user's call so we'll create another
class here
user api
view so i will not use a view set now
i will use an api view
api view here so let's import it
from rest firm framework views we'll
import api view
and this will be really simple we need
to
define the get function
and we need the parameter here which is
a request
which we won't use it i will put an
underscore here
we have to get the users users
user sorry objects all
so let's import also user from the
models
so we imported it here now we got the
user
we have to get a random user so
here i will import
random
to get a random user
is equal to random choice
users and this will be a random user now
let's return
the id response
id is user.id
so this is a user so let's add it also
to the urls
the path will be user and we have to
import it here
user api view
user api view here as view
so let's test this route
so this will be a get request to the
user
this returns an error because we don't
have any users in the database
so i will manually add here some values
so i'll add here one
two three
four and five so i'll add five users
or five numbers now let's send the
request again and i get
five if i send it again it's four so
the result is randomized
so this was our main app
now we have to create another app so we
can communicate
it so that the other app will be a flask
app
now it's time to create the main app and
i decided to make it with
flask so i created a main folder
and inside i created an empty main.pi
file
so let's start first i'll paste here
the requirements that we need
so we need to install flask flask sql
alchemy sql alchemy
flask migrate flash scripts flash course
request
mysql client and pica so there are a lot
of
requirements that we need and now
we will go to the other project and i
will copy the docker files here
and paste them here
so the docker file
will be the same here except for
the command which will be simpler
just python main
dot pi so this
will be the docker file a docker compose
file for
mysql it will be the same except this
will be a new port
i'll put 7 here and i will change the
database name to main
there is no need to change the database
name because this is another container
but
we changed it so the port the default
port for
flask will be 5000
and 8000 is occupied with
the jungle up so i will use 8001 here
and that's it so the docker files are
completed
now let's create a flask up here
so from flask
import flask
let's create the app is equal to flask
name here
so let's start a basic app so
here i will add new route up route
so just slash i'll create a function
index and
here i will return just hello
so let's see if this works
so i need to add a condition if name
is equal to main
then up run
with debug is equal to true
we also need the host so the host will
be
0.0.0.0
so that's it now let's try to run it
without a docker container
python 3
main.play so we got this port
let's copy it
and open a new tab in postman
so we have an error
so is hello not sure why throw the
narrow
now let's do the same but this time with
docker so we have all the requirements
we don't need to change anything so
let's start
docker compose up
and let's wait till it's completed
so it's finished we can see a db data
folder here
and uh let's test it now
the port will not be 5000 because this
will be inside the docker container
the port will be 8001 so
here i'll change it with localhost
port 8001
and that's it so we can see hello now
so docker is working
now let's add mysql to
this main.pi file
so let's import sql alchemy
so from flask
sql alchemy
import sql alchemy
and we need to use it here so up
config
and we need to set a constant so
is sql alchemy
underscore database
underscore uri so with this
we will add the db connection and
what we need is to add mysql here
and here we need to add the user
and the password so root root in our
case
at now we need the host the host will be
the service here which is db so the host
will be db
and in the end will be the table which
is main
so with this we can connect to this
database
i will add also of course here
since the front end will need it so
let's
import it from flask course
i'll add it to the app and
now the database
is equal to sql alchemy
and here we'll pass up now let's create
two models that we need so class
product this will extend from db
model and
let's add all the required properties
for the
product we need the id which is
a db column
db integer
and also is a primary key
now we have to make another change for
the
id here we will add here
auto increment to false why did i
add this field because the product
will not be created in this app the
product
will be created in the jungle app
and this app will just catch the event
from rabbitmq
and it will create the product
and when we create the product we don't
want the id to be
auto increment because the id will be
different than the
the jungle up so if we want the same id
we have to put it on to incremental
false and
to insert directly the id as it is from
the django app
so we'll see by example a little bit
later
now let's add the title
db column
db string and this will be a
200 character let's do the same for the
image
so this is a product notice that
uh this product will be different than
the product from
the other app because we don't have
likes here
and the id is different so we can you
we can think this as a different type of
uh the same thing let's add also another
class that we need each
which is product
user from db
model so this will have an id
which is a
column db integer
primary key to true so
this will increment normally
we need here the user id
which is a db column db integer
and the same for the product id
we need also a unique
constraint
for user id
product id
and we need to set the name which is a
user product
unique so this
unique constraint so let's import it
from
sql alchemy from here
so this unique constraint
will make sure that the combination of
user id and product id
should be unique we should not repeat it
so we created the models that we will
use now
we need to migrate so to migrate
i will create a new file here i'll call
it
manager
and now here we need some imports
so first from the main app
we need to import up and db
we need to import from flask
migrate we need to import
migrate and migrate command and from
flask script we need to import manager
now migrate will be equal to
migrate with our app and our db
here then we have to get
to the manager so manager is equal to
manager
we need to pass the app inside and the
will add the command db
we'll add the migrate command here so
we will have a db command to run our
migrations
so we will see it now that we will add
the
if name
is equal to main so
we need to add manager run
and that's it so if we open the terminal
now
and open a new tab we'll run here docker
compose exec backend
sh and now we are inside the
docker container now if we run python
manager dot pi
and we will run the command db
so we added the command here with help
we can see now that we have a command
that we can
run now let's migrate
so to migrate we have to run python
manager dot py
db init
so we created some migration files
we can see them here now we need to
migrate them so
now around python manage
dot pi db migrate
so it should be python
manager that pi db
migrate
so we created a new table if we open the
database
now we'll connect with the database
so this will be 7 here
the user is root password is also root
and the database will be main
so let's connect
we'll see a database now with the
emblemic version but we won't see our
tables
because we need to run another command
for it
which is python manage
that manager sorry that pi
db upgrade
and now we run the migration if we
refresh we'll see the
table so this is a product table and
this is a
product user table
so this is how we connect flask with
mysql using docker
now it's time to use rabbitmq to our
python apps
so i will use this service cloud ampq
and you have to create a free account
this is the free account i already have
created so i can log in
so this is my free account and what i
will do here
is this ampq url i will just copy it
and now i can move to the app so i will
go to the jungle app
and uh in the products here i'll create
a python file
producer
and for the moment i will just copy this
url
now let's send an event to rabbitmq
so first we have to import pica
this is a package that will help us
send events and let's create a variable
params is equal to pica
url parameters and here we can put the
url that we just
pasted here as a string
so we created the params this is
annoying the connection now
is equal to
pica blocking connection
and we will pass the params here
so we created the connection with
rabbitmq
now we have to create the channel which
is equal to connection
channel so with this
we created the channel now we can
publish so
to publish i will create a function
publish inside i will put a method
and a body so
for a moment i will just keep it empty
so we can
see an example of the publish
method so channel here basic
publish we need to put an exchange
i will put an empty string routing key
this is a queue that we want to send the
event
so for the moment i will put it admin so
i will
publish it in the same queue as this one
with the hit we need the body which is
for the moment hello
so that's it we can use this publish
function now
i will use it in the views when we
list the products i'll just publish here
so i imported the function and
when we retrieve all the products we
will publish hello
now we created the producer now we need
to create the consumer so
here we need to create the consumer
so the beginning is the same
let's copy everything from the the
producer
paste it here and now we have to declare
a queue so channel
cue declare
and the queue will be admin
so now we need the callback so call back
this accepts a channel as a parameter
method properties
and body let's pass for the moment
after the callback we have to call
channel basic consume
here we have to pass the queue which is
admin
and we have to pass on message callback
which is this callback that we just
created
so we are basically consuming now
we can print
started consuming
since we want to have a message to see
if
we started consuming and the channel
start consuming
so with this in the end we'll close it
so channel
close so we
basically have finished now let's uh
print a message also to
know if we received a message so print
here
re sieve
in admin so
we received a message and i will print
the body here
if we go to hello there
so that's it now let's try to open the
terminal go to the docker file so docker
compose
exec backend sh
here we have to call consumer.pi so
python
consumer.pine
so we received this messages because i
already
sent some test events now
let's test it let's go to the route
for the products and we can expect when
we get the products here to send an
event hello there
send we can
we can see now we received an event
hello
now let's consume to the flask app so
what i will do is
copy this consumer file go to the flask
app
and here i'll paste the consumer
so everything is the same except the
queue here will be
main
so we are done
now i can
so i can start it with
pub python consumer
dot pi so we started consuming
and in the producer here i will change
the
routing key to main
so now i will not publish here in the
admin app
but i will publish here in the main app
so let's see if this makes any
difference
let's send the event we can see
hello here was from before
but this received the hello now so
to see the difference
hello main i will say hello main
so let's send it again
we don't see a hello main here but we
will see it here so this
is how we send events
to different apps using pica and
rabbitmq
now we successfully connect us with
rabbitmq and we started consuming uh
with the both apps now
we don't want to have all the time to
tabs here to start the consumer
so we'll change the docker compose file
now
first let's change the docker file
we will cut this command here
and we will add it directly here
so when we build we'll execute the
command
that we just cut so this is basically
the same as before
we run the command here but now we are
running it
here we did that because we will create
another
container now so is q i will call it
which will have the same docker file
and the the difference now is we will
start a command now
and the command will be python
consumer dot pi so we will run
the command directly here instead of
manually running it
every time this also depends on the
database
because we will insert data later
so let's do the same for the flask app
so i'll paste
the queue here
so this file is the same so the
difference now
is i will cut this command here
and i will put it here
command python main api
so now let's restart
all the containers so i will run docker
compose up build
now we don't need the other tab
let's do the same for this also let's
remove this
tab and we will
build all the containers now we are
building the queue
so as we can see we are
getting the q so the q is here
so one other thing that we can make
is by running it like this a docker
compose
up minus d for the
database so d
means we won't see the logs
let's do the same for the backend or
for the back end and the queue we need
to see the
logs so now we are seeing the logs from
the queue
and from the back end
let's do the same here so
minus d here db and docker compose
up
now let's see if this works so
we are the products here let's send the
request again
we won't see it here but we should see
it here
also another change that we have to make
if we close our containers
and run them again we'll notice so
if i do it with a database like this
and the others double compose up
you will notice that i will still get
the
cues but they they are not consumed yet
so
there is one last change that we have to
add in our consumer
and here we have to add auto ack
true
so with this we will consume the
calls and we will not get them again
so let's do the same for the
other consumer and let's restart
the containers again with build
also this one
will build
so they are rebuilt now if we do the
same
with the database and we
start the other apps
we will see that the queue started
consuming but
we cannot see anything here so that's it
now with uh these changes
consuming becomes easier
now we want to send events every time a
product is created updated or deleted
so we have to change this publish method
we will add here a method and a body
so for the method
we have to create variable properties
which is equal to pica basic
properties and here we will pass a
method
and here we'll pass the properties is
equal to properties
also for the body so we need to
import json here and the body will be
json dumps
body so we will send objects or anything
but we have to
convert it to json before we send it
so this is our publish function now
let's use it to our views let's remove
this publish here
and now when we create we will publish
product created
and we will send the serial laser the
data
let's do the same for product updated
product updated
and for the product deleted
now instead of the object we'll send
directly the primary key
so these are the main events that we
want to send
and now let's make changes to the flask
app
here we have to get the
data which is equal to json so i will
import json here
json loads
body so in the django app we will
convert it to json so now we will con
convert it back
let's print it so we can see what data
are we sending
and now we'll make the condition if
properties
content type
is equal to product created
will create the project so the product
sorry
so the product is equal to product
with an id data
id here title
so let's import also this product here
is equal to data title
and image is equal to data
image in the end
let's import also the db
db session add
product ndb session
commit so this is how you create a
an object with sql alchemy
now let's do the same for the other
conditions so
properties content type
product updated
so now we will get the product
is equal to product query
get data with an id
and we have to change this product so
product
title is equal to data
with the title and the image
so
image here in the end we will
call session commit
the last change is deleting so
properties
content type product deleted
and in this case we'll get the product
like this
but we don't send an object we
send directly the id so this data is the
id
we have to do it like this now db
session
delete product
and tb session commit
so these are all the three cases
that we will receive
from the other app now let's see
if they work but before
we should restart our
containers just to be sure so
build
so there is no need to restart this one
but
just let's do it to be sure
so this is started and now
we have the products here which we don't
have any
let's create a product here i will
send some data
title
is a title here and the image
an image
let's send the request so we
successfully created pro
the product in the django app but let's
see if we created it in the
uh flask app
so we received the queue we probably
forgot we should add here
some print statements like
product created
product updated and product
deleted but doesn't matter let's see the
database
and we can see this is a product now so
we successfully created
the product from an event from rabbitmq
now let's try to update it so this
product
will put send a put request with a new
title and a new image
so i will not save it let's send the
request
this is updated and if we see the event
we got the new title and a new image
we don't see the print that we just
added because we have to rebuild the
containers
now we're just checking the database
which is correct
and now let's try to delete it
and this is received
and if we refresh here
we can see we have no product so
now the databases for the product are in
sync from
the jungle app and for the flask app
so we completed the jungle app now let's
finish
the flask up since we have only one
route here
so let's change this route to just
api slash products
and here we'll return a list of products
so let's import jsonify
from flask here
and we will return jsonify
product query
all so
let's see if this works
so let's see if this works
so the endpoint is api slash
products and we got
one product let's create
one product here so we can see it if it
works
so we got this product that we just
created
so we should see it in the database
notice that the id is three so when we
created this product we don't start with
one but the
idea that we have it on our django app
now let's send the request and we get an
error
because object of type product is not
json serializable
to fix this error we have to add here
it data class
and let's import it from data classes
so with this now the
class will be json serializable let's do
the same for
the product user
send the request again and
we got an md object but we want to see
the data which we got id title and image
here
to do it we have to declare it here id
should be an int
title should be a string
str so and image
should be a string
with these changes now we can
see the id image and the title
so with this we completed the main route
now let's add another route so
i'll call it like and this
will have up
route api
products we need the
idea of the product which is an integer
the id and
we have to like it so this is the end
point the method
is a post request
and when we like we will send an id
here so
how do we like the product so now it's a
little bit complicated we have to
internally call
the django up so we have to internally
call this
user api view here to get a random id
and we have to assign it to the product
user so
first we have to create a variable i
will call it rec
and this will call requests
dot get let's import requests
from so we import directly requests here
and now we have to get
the endpoint so the endpoint is http
localhost port 8000
slash api slash user
and for the moment we will just return
json if i request
json not sure if i
need jsonify here but let's try it
so
products with an id1 we need to like it
let's send a post request send
and we get an error connection refused
so what is the error here there
is localhost here because right now we
are
inside the docker container and the
localhost inside the docker container is
0.0.0
how to connect with another docker
container localhost
we have to specify here that this is
docker for mac
localhost so this
is the way the docker knows that we are
referring not the
container localhost but another
localhost so
our local localhost so with this change
let's try to send it again it seems we
the server stops so we probably need to
restart it
send it again and now we got id2
so this is id from the user so
this will be user here
so not post get
so this endpoint 8001
will call this other endpoint
now that we got the response let's use
it
and create a product user
so here we will
get a json is request.json
in the end if it is successful we will
return a message
success
and we will make a try
accept here so what we
will try is we will create a product
user
which is equal to product user
with user id is equal
to json
id and the product id
is equal to the id that we just set this
one
from the url and now that we
set this product user we have to add it
db
session add product user
and we have to commit
and here we'll send an event
which i will send it later
and if an error happens there
is when the user tries to
like again because this is an unique
constraint
if that happens we will abort
let's import a board
from flask board we'll put 400 here
and you already
liked this product
so a board we imported from from flask
here
so let's try it let's send the request
again
send success
if we see the database product user we
created one
and it will happen that we will fail
it seems that our unique constraint
didn't work
so i probably made a mistake here but i
won't focus on that let's finish
this up by sending an event
now we need to get the producer
i'll copy the same producer here
so everything now is the same and
we have to use it here
now if this is completed we have to add
here producer
so publish
let's import it product
liked and we have to pass the id of the
product
so let's we need to import it here
so this is our flask app
only one thing that i think is easy
fixable
now let's make the last change here on
the consumer
we will get the data here
which is equal so let's import json
json loads
body let's print the data
and we here will like the product so
we'll get a product first which is equal
to product
let's import it so from products models
we'll import product
that objects
get id is equal to data
so i will directly make this an id
so we got the id now product
likes will equal to product
likes plus one
so we will increment it by one in the
end we'll save it
and we will print that product
is product likes
increased
just to be sure let's
rebuild the containers
and we will rebuild this too
so this is completed now
we have the products here
so we have two products
and they have zero likes now for the
product with an id2
let's see if we have that product in the
main
so three i guess so
for the product with id3 i'll post here
to like it
and this should increase the likes
so i guess we have an error
received in main
so my bed when i made the producer
i should change here the routing key
should be
admin so
let's rebuild
and this should receive the event
now let's like again not here
here so this
should not receive the event it didn't
this did receive the event
actually we got an error here so
requested setting installed ups but
settings are not configured
this error happens because this file is
outside
of django and we are using the product
here
and to use a product regularly we have
to
load so we have to set up jungle before
getting the product so we have to import
here
os and django
we have to set uh an environment
variable django sent is
sending settings module is equal to
admin settings
so this settings here and
we have to add django setup here
with this we won't have that error so
let's rebuild the containers we can see
now that we started consuming so
let's try it again
now we success let's send it again and
we
see the likes are increased here so we
received the event
so now we are communicating back and
forth with
both apps so this was
the app that i wanted to show now it's
time to create the react
frontend i'll create a
react project with typescript so
to create it write mpx
create react app
i will call it react crud
and the template will be typescript
let's wait till it's completed
now the project is created we can go to
the folder
and run npm start
now the project is running and if you
open the browser
we can see on localhost port 3000
we have our app running now let's open
the project with our ide
and this is the project that we just
created all the files
are in typescript so i will remove the
app.test.tsx file
we won't be using uh tests here in this
tutorial
and now let's add the template for
this project so we don't use the default
react template
go to getbootstrap.com
examples and i will go to the dashboard
here
and get this template so let's view the
page source
and i will copy the html from the body
till the end
so and i will paste it here
so my id is smart so all
class now are have been converted to
class name
if your id doesn't do that you make sure
to
do it yourself so i will remove all
these
tr's here because there are a lot
and i will keep only one so
i will keep only this we don't need the
canvas
we don't need the buttons so
let's make some changes so we can remove
this ul
nh6 so
this can be removed also so we can keep
the dashboard
and let's remove this pan
so let's make everything much simpler so
we
remove the ally here
so we have an error here also which
is the error so there is
this input which we need to add a slash
here
and everything should be
correct now let's remove this logo here
and it will look ugly
so if we see our app it looks very ugly
because we need to add also the styles
so here we have the dashboard.css
which we have to copy it and add it to
our
app css paste it here
and now it will look a little bit better
but
we also need to add bootstrap so go to
bootstrapcdn.com and here we need to
copy the
html link and add it to our index.html
now that we added this link it will look
much better so this is a template
we will be using
so let's make further changes
so i'll create two components now this
is
the navigation
so i will create a folder
components inside i will create a new
component
i'll create it now and will be
typescript.jsx file
inside i will create a stateless react
component
and i will use this shortcut in my ide
so we need to import react from react
we need to create our component as a
constant
and this is a function which we need to
export in the end
here is html so the html
let's cut this part here
and paste it in our nav so let's
replace it now that we
replace the html we can use the
component directly here
so let's call it
nav my id
auto imports components so
you should import now from components
nav here
and use it directly if we see the
browser
nothing will change let's create another
component now which is the menu which is
this one
so let's do the same
menu
create the component and let's
cut html
actually the name here will not be
dashboard will be products
and let's use the menu in our app.esx
so that's it now everything looks much
more simpler
and our component looks much better
now we need to create more components
for our app
so we will have two main apps so one is
the admin and the second one
is the main app
so first we will focus with the admin
which is
what we have been doing till now
and then we will create the main app
so inside the admin app we need to
create the products component
so let's create another component
products
let's let it be a jsx typescript file
and this component
for html will have the html
for this table basically so let's
cut it and let's
paste it here
so note that react doesn't allow to have
two html elements
nearby each other they all need to be
wrapped
inside a bigger one so this makes
sense either that or
i will just remove the section title so
i will keep it much more cleaner this
way
now let's add these products
here so one way is to add directly the
product
here but we don't want to do
this because we will create more
components which
they will change here nav and menu will
stay the same but this will change
so uh to fix this we have to
install another package we see which is
react
router dom so open the terminal and
write
npm install react
router dom and types
react router dom
we need this second package because
the first one is javascript package and
the second one
is the typescript package so for
all the typescript apps you need
to do it this way
now reactor router dom is installed
now we have to use it here so to
map the products via the router we have
to import two packages
so the first one is browser router
and the second one is route
not router route so
let's replace this products here
and inside we'll add browser router
this is a container for all our routes
and let's add our first route which is
for the products so
we have to specify a path the path for
products will be admin
slash products
and the second parameter we need to add
the component
which in our case is the products
so that's it so
this is a path we can reference the
products now
so right now nothing is happening
because we are at the
main app so if we go to
admin slash products we can see we can
see the table now
so this is working
now let's add the main template so
let's go again to get bootstrap.com
to the examples and this will be the
template for our
main app so let's copy the code
from the body so from here
till here and we have to create a new
component for main
main here
let's create a component and here we'll
paste
the html we just cut so
let's remove most of the
call md4 here because
we don't need all of them
so we keep only one
we don't need neither the
jump drone here and neither the header
so we can remove the header
and this is
almost what it will look like
so we will make changes later but for
now
i will remove also the svg here
so for now let's create
a route for this so
the route for the main app will be route
the path will be the main path so slash
and the component
will be the main component
don't forget to import it so if we go to
the main component
now it will look
so first this is what
the product component looks like which
is
weird and also if we go to the main page
we can see this is what the main
component looks like but
we don't want the navigation in the menu
here
so what is that we are making a mistake
so first we need
to remove the nav and menu from
this route so the only way to do it is
by creating a new
wrapper component for the admin
so let's do it
let's create here a typescript file
called wrapper
so inside i will create a component
and the html for that component will be
this
nav and the menu so
i will cut this part
go to the wrapper and paste it here
so inside the div let's also
cut what i left here
and paste it so
this is now the wrapper component
so why do we need this component so we
have to use it directly
in our products so we can wrap this with
the wrapper
so wrapper
and now in this component we will use
the
menu and nav so we are having an error
here
because we are not using it correctly
inside here we have to use
the child properties that we have so we
have to add here props
uh we are having an error also here
because we are
using typescript we have to specify a
type which is
props with children
any so these are the props that we have
and
to pass the child properties we have to
use props
children
this way we will
pass the html inside here
to the rubber and
if we go to the this is the main
app now which looks much better and if
you
if you go to the admin slash products
still doesn't look good
still we see this main
card so
what is the issue here the issue is
this slash the problem with
this slash is that they both have slash
and
react confuses them and to solve that
we have to use exact here this means
that the path is exact here
and don't confuse it with the other
paths with this
products will look the same as
before and the main
app will look different
so this is how we use
route so let's remove nav and menu we
don't need it here
actually these components which are nav
and menu we have to move it to our admin
because they belong there don't forget
also to
change the imports here
which my id does it automatically
so now we got the admin the main app
which we will use it later and now let's
focus on our products
component now let's fill
the table for the products
to fill the table first we have to get
all the products and to do it we have to
use
use effect
and inside accepts
a function as a parameter and the second
parameter
will be an empty array this
empty array means that this will be
called only once
if we put a variable that changes
use effect will be called every time the
variable changes
we'll see this later on
now inside here we need to call our
backend
to get our data so
we cannot make this use effect
asynchronous here
it doesn't accept it so the way to do it
is to create a function
get products and this will be an
asynchronous function
and in the end we will call it
so get products this is a way to call
asynchronous functions in
react but there is an even easier way
so we can remove get products totally
so let's open a parenthesis here and
close the parenthesis
when we call it so
this is my preferred way of calling
asynchronous functions
in react so open parenthesis close
parenthesis
and then you call it directly
here inside now let's call our backend
let's get a response
is equal to await fetch
the endpoint would be http localhost
port 8000 slash
api slash products
once we get the response we have to get
the data
which is equal to a weight response
json so we got all the data
so first let's console.log it
and inspect here
we will see that we get the products
here and
the console log works so we got all the
products
now we have to get them and loop them to
do it we have to use
another react hook command which is use
state
so use state
accepts a default first parameter so
a default value which is an empty uh
array
for the products and the returns
products as a variable and set
products as a function so these
work together with each other once we
set the products
these products get set so set products
will be used here
data now we set the products
it means this variable has changed so
we have to use that variable here
let's use it so
we have to map it so products
map it will
return a product that
returns this
html so the
we need to add a key here so for every
loop that we have we have to have a key
now we are having a type error here
because we have to cast
the product here so we have to create a
folder here
interfaces and inside will create
a product interface so
product not products but
product
here we'll export an interface product
and this interface will have an id as a
number
a title as a string
an image as a string
and it will have
likes as a number
so this is a product that we have
let's go back and now we have to
cast this product as
product don't forget also to import it
here
so we have the key now
now let's call every other variable so
this is id
i also forgot here to put the headers so
the first one is the image
this is a title this is a likes
and this is the action
so the second one is the
image so we have to put an image here
with the source to be product that
image and the height will be
180.
this is a product title
and this is a product
likes for the moment i will
keep actions to an empty td
now let's see it on the browser so we
retrieved
products with images so for some reason
the image doesn't show so
this site lorem pixel doesn't work
uh currently for me but if it works
it will show images here so this is how
we retrieve products
and we loop them to show them as a table
now let's delete a product in the
actions
here we need to add some more html
so i will add this html which is just a
button
delete so we want to delete a product
so first let's create a delete function
i will call it d deal not delete because
it's a keyword
so this function
will accept an id as a number
and we have to call it here so
to do it we have to add the non-click
listener
and we have to call
the delete function with
the product id so
this is how we call
the delete function for a different
product
now that we have the delete product we
have to make it asynchronous and we have
to call our backend to remove the
product
so to do it we have to
make a weight method
fetch so i will copy this part here
so in this case now we need to pass
the id so i will
convert the quotes here to this kind of
quotes
i don't know the name of these quotes
but
with this codes you can add
variables to the string which is the id
in this
case this is not a get request
this is a get request but we want to
make a delete request here
so we have to pass some parameters
so the method
will be delete
so with this function call
we will delete a product in the back end
but we
need also to remove it from the front
end
so we have to call set products again
so set products and we have to get
all the products except the product that
have this
id so we have to get
all the products
and we have to filter them
and the filter will have the product
as a product id so product is a product
here
and we will filter
all the products that have the id
different than this id
we can keep it one liner here
so this means that we are getting all
the products
except this product id and we are
setting it so
the table refreshes itself
one last change that we need here is to
add a confirmation
since we don't want to delete the
products directly
so we add a new condition here
window dot confirm are you sure
you want to delete
this product
and we close
all what we did
inside this if statement so once we
click
delete the browser will ask this
question
if we type yes then the product will
will be deleted
let's see it on the browser so i will
delete
product number four when i click i will
get a question
are you sure you want to delete this
product i type
ok then we can see
product with id4 is removed if i refresh
it's also removed in the backend so this
is
how we delete products
now let's create some products first
let's create
a new rear component products
create and this
will be a normal react component
and now that we created it we
have to add it to our router so
the route for this component will be
admin products slash create
and this will be products create
let's make every component exact
so we don't have any problems
this also
now let's go to our products we will add
here
this html it's just a link
and we will have to change this anchor
link to a
link from react router dom so
i automatically imported it but you have
to do it on your own so
import link from react router dom
and this link will redirect to
admin
products create
let's add a slash in front
and we don't need this curly braces so
this is the link that we want so
if we see the browser we can see an add
button here that
when we click we go to the products
create page
which is empty right now so in the
products create
let's convert this div to just wrapper
and now it looks better
inside here i will create this simple
form
that accepts only a title and an image
and a button to save it so it will look
like this
now let's make this form work
first we have to create variables
from the state for the title and the
image so
we'll create the title set
title from
use state
and the default value will be empty
let's do the same for the image
so this is image and this is
set image
now that we got the variables
we can set it directly here
so when we change this input we have to
set
the title so we had an
unchanged listener here
and the event will call set
title and the value will be event that
target that value
this means every time this input changes
so
when we type here we'll set the title
so let's do it the same for the image so
on change event we'll call
set image event.target.value
now in this title an image we got the
values that the
user set so we are ready to use them
in when the form is submitted so
let's add an onsubmit
call here let's create also the function
submit
and for the moment just console.log
the title and the image
and on the submit here we will call the
submit function
so let's test it on the browser let's
inspect
and let's put the title here and
an image save
i saw console log but immediately the
page
refreshed so that is a problem so we
have to
prevent that and to do it we have to
call
here to to add an event parameter here
and to call event.
prevent default typescript
wants us to type the event here so
synthetic
event
let me type it synthetic
event so
that will prevent the page refresh
so if we try it again
we can see that we consult log test and
test
now we are ready to call the backend to
create
our product so let's make this
function asynchronous
and here we'll call
weight fetch
http localhost port 8000
slash api slash products
and we have to add some
options the first one
is a method which is a post method
the second one is the headers so this is
a
http request so we want to work with
json so we have to add content
type application
slash json
and we need also to send the data which
are these
two variables that we have here so we
have to send them
in the body and we have to
stringify them so json
stringify because it accepts a string
we want to send an object so
we need to add the title here
and the image
note that this title here is the same as
title title here
but to keep it short and simple
we can use it like this now we can
create products with this request
we need one more change because
we want to redirect to the products once
we submit the form so let's create
another state here
i will call it redirect
and set redirect
use state and the default value will be
false here i will add the condition
if redirect we want to
return redirect
so let's import it so importer direct
from react router dom
we want to redirect to admin
slash products
and once we create a product
we want to set redirect to true
so this means if this is successful
we redirect to the main table
let's try it out let's create a product
title image save
so if we redirect it means it works
so we can see it did work so let's
create another one with a correct
image and let's put a title here
bird
so we can see this is working correctly
and the redirect works correctly
now we want to edit products to edit
products
is almost the same as creating products
so i will
copy the products create component
and paste it and change the name to
products edit
let's rename also this variable products
edit and rename this also products edit
so now that we created products edit
let's add it also to our routes
let's duplicate this and the route now
is different
so we need to go to admin slash product
slash
id slash edit
we need the id of the product that we
want to edit
and the component is products
edit
now we need to get the product
from this id that we are fetching but
first
let's go to our products and here we
need to add another link
let's copy the link for the delete and
name it
edit we don't need a non-click listener
here
but we have to rename this to a link
and we have to redirect to
the path that we want to redirect is
admin slash products slash
the id so product dot id here slash
edit
and don't forget to end it with the link
here
so this button will appear on the table
now
so along with the delete button now we
have an edit button
let's click the edit button and right
now
nothing happens so i made a mistake
a spelling mistake here so it's products
here
let's go back and type edit again let's
refresh
just in case so this is the product
edit form now we have product with id
number two we have to set the titles and
the image for the product with id number
two
so to do it let's go to products edit
now
we have to call use effect
and inside here we need to
call our backend for that product
so like we did before i will open two
braces here and make a sync function
so this is my way of calling uh
an sync function inside use effect
inside here we need to call the backend
so response is equal to weight
fetch let me copy this
part here so i will use this braces
now we need the id of the product so we
have to get a product with the id
that we got from the url to
get it we have to add the props here
and this time is props with
reference and
based on the props now the id
is props
match params dot
id
the id here corresponds to
this id here so the the actual name
and to get the query params we have to
use
props match params
now we get the response
let's get also the product
which is equal to a weight response.json
once we got the product we have to set
the title and the image
based on this product so set title
to product dot title
set image product dot
image we can cast this product as a
product here since it is a product
so let's see how this looks
on the browser now and this is not
working because we forgot to add
something else
we set the values but this doesn't mean
that the inputs will
reflect that value so we have to add
here
a default value for the title
same for the other input so default
value will be image here
now once this change the input will
change also
now we can see the data are pre-filled
based on the product so if i change this
from number two to number one
we can see we have different values
the last change we need is to change
this fetch now
this now is a different url
we'll call api product slash
props match params
that id and the method is
put
all of the other things are the same
now let's test it on the browser so
i will change the image to this image
and i will say updated
title for the product with id
1 let's save it now i'm redirected
and we can see a new image and an
updated title
so this is how we update
products now
let's complete the main app
so this should be a list of products
so let's create
products from the state so products
set products
equals to use state and
the products will be an empty array in
the beginning
now we have to get all the products so
we have to use
use effect
an empty array a function sorry
and this will be an empty array inside
here
we'll call our backend so
this will be an async function
will get response
from fetch http localhost
port 8001 now
so before it was 8 000 now it's 8001
api slash products
once we get the response we have to get
the data which is equal to
weight response dot json
i forgot a weight here
and in the end we have to set the
products
to this data that we got
now we set the products we have to loop
them here
so this is the html that we want to loop
so products
map
we have to get every product
and return this html
so this needs a key
product.id this
needs the product to be cast to product
so let's make the other changes now
first we need an image here
so let's write an image stack
with the source to be
product that image
height will be 180.
this is the product
title here
here we need to only one button which is
like
and this is a number of likes
so it's not minutes this should be
likes likes so that's it
let's see how it looks like let's go to
the main app
and this is what it looks like so we
have only two
images that work because the other that
don't work
but this is the main idea now let's make
this
like function work so
let's add a new click here
on click and this will call the function
like so this will be like this
like with the product id
let's make the like function
this will have an id as a number
so this works fine now let's complete
the like function let's make this
asynchronous here
and this will call our backend
here we need to wait fetch
the url is almost the same here
let's change it to these brackets and
the
the endpoint is api slash product slash
the id that we got as a parameter
slash like and this
will be a post request
we need also to send some data but
in this case we don't need any data so
we need
only to send the headers which is
content
type application
slash json
usually the post requests have some data
but in this case we don't have any
now that we like a product we also need
to
update this html so we need to set the
products
again so to set the products
we need to loop and change all
the current products so set products
products map
and for every product
we have to make a condition now if
this product that id is equal to this
id that we got as a parameter here
then product that legs
will increase in the end
return the product so this means
that only this product with this id
will increase the likes
now we are having an error like
argument of type product is not
assignable of parameter of type
set state action never
this means that when we initialize the
products here this
is never
this typescript interprets this is never
like this
so to fix this problem we have to
manually cast
this empty array as product
array so this is an empty array
but as a product array and immediately
we see
that we don't have an error anymore
so this is how we fix typescript errors
by casting
the products directly let's open the
browser now
and if we like a product
we can see the number of likes increases
and that's it is very is very simple
so this was our app that we wanted to
build
and i hope you like it
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
for more content
thank you